hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to shadow of Rose
picking up where we left off we found
our dad uh who is dead but alive but
dead well that looks familiar what's all
this doing out here that's the key
or the thing that was related to the key
oh do I have my gun back oh I have my
gun back well that's awfully convenient
I forgot that I even had that
and I have uh well I don't need to craft
anything right now because I don't even
know what I need to do man that's in a
terrible order but whatever I got my gun
so whatever Evils are lurking in the
darkness I'm sure I'll be fine and I'm
sure they're not giving me all this ammo
for no reason so I'm sure I'm after I'm
going to have to shoot something what is
that oh my God
what is this place oh that's so cool
that that's one of the coolest visuals
I've ever seen I love the whole thing
like I think it was in berserk and you
know the Dark Souls games and all these
kind of things where it's like it's it's
an evolution of an eclipse this is a new
thing I have not seen this that is dope
that's dope that's super cool that's so
cool
God
and then there's a big butthole right
there a prolapse stain is right there
head for the giant core yeah yeah sure
all right whatever you say pal I think
this is where
um Chris Redfield traveled down with his
big old machine gun
I me is that me hi
[Music]
okay all right Birds thanks
Odin here or something
yeah okay that was weird
okay
um well good for me
I do recall that in the other one this
was the last area so I have a funny
feeling that's probably going to be a
bit final over here as well
approaching the end of this really cool
DLC but still Lady D is escaping
just like in the castle just like in the
castle hey isn't that the statue from
the castle
I guess we didn't resolve our situation
with the the big fellow okay no
oh boy
I should probably not
whoa what was that about oh
yeah I am
cool
I'm freaking strong bro
strong as hell
all right did I get everything I need I
probably missed something over there I'm
oh God
[Music]
get out of here get out of here
whoa whoa what are you doing stop that
oh I don't know why I thought that you
were someone to save you're just another
oh they're all me
oh they're all me oh stop
oh God come on here we go
oh God
wait hold on there
I don't know if I need to kill all you
but I have a limited amount of white
sage so whoa whoa whoa whoa
it's the other thing I missed from the
other one is that I can't exactly oh I
could have just gone forward at any time
I agree
I concur but at the same time is this
just going to be a discovery or a
journey of self-discovery where I'm like
oh The Power Within Me was good all
along so long as I master it and the
journey to get there is what gave me the
understanding and appreciation for who I
am as is the prolapse Thanos oh oh
God I don't appreciate what's inside of
me oh God I don't appreciate anything
about any of this
[Laughter]
oh God that is all oh no you know
there's no need God there's no need oh
man there is so no need for any of this
wow okay
down I go then is this where I fought
mother Miranda
uh I'm sure I'm sure
all right God as soon as I go outside
I'm like oh the visuals have never been
better the visuals have never been worse
is that a knife that's an eye
Mark I had intended to duplicate
Rosemary Winters with the hope that a
perfect replica might serve a suitable
vessel however the results were less
than ideal it would seem that some sort
of interference is preventing me from
creating a superdupal replica instead
I've succeeded in making what is
essentially a living doll it resembles
the real thing yes but has no power such
a pathetic husk could never prove
suitable as a vessel I will continue my
efforts in hopes of Discerning the
source of this interference several
hypotheses have come to mind so far the
fact that Rose herself is still alive
some other actor within this realm a
flaw in my method of production none of
these seems especially likely to be the
sole reason nor are any of them easy to
problems to solve perhaps my best hope
is to somehow bring Rose into this realm
where she to offer herself as a vessel
it would be so simple additional
observations
I need to hit my computer this is what I
was talking about everybody
shut up I literally have to hit it to
shut it up further experiments with
these Rose copies as I've taken to
calling these husks have yielded another
interesting wrinkle to pursue when
subjected to situations evoking extreme
Terror they actually begin to express
some semblance of rose's abilities this
warrants more research and I think that
my first Creation The Masked Duke is
just the one to perform this stress test
I mean they may have
okay so I'm beginning to think that the
person that lured me in here originally
this so-called friend of mine was uh the
one who did this it would seem that at
some point during my experiments with
Consciousness an intruder made herself
at home in my realm this Intruder was
none other than the failure eveline who
has been running about enacting her own
pitiful agenda which has led to a slight
disruption in my plans had Evelyn not
interfered Rose Winters would have been
on the verge of despair dispossessed of
her will to live in her mutomycy powers
instead a new passion Burns within her I
shall have to extinguish it
well oh God is this your
plants
so terrible
but at least I'm getting a lot of ammo
that's always good
great can't wait to do this boss battle
I'll do the pistol at first just to find
out what the weaknesses are and then
I'll go in for the kill with the shout
gun and then I will be able to finish
this once and for all
oh good white goo
is that feeling again
so strong it must be the crystal what
must be what feeling that that well I've
been feeling close but I just can't go
any further I thought that I made it
when I saw that blue light but no not
quite if only I'd been braver faster
stronger so close
I'm so close
[Music]
my goal
you mean Ethan Winters
Ethan Winters oh they're here is it
through here how do you know also what
is here what are you what are you doing
in that Lake what's all those spikes for
you lonely in there you trying to do
some environmental storytelling hello
how are you black God which lives in us
and in which we live create for us a new
world as befits your will your dark
Consciousness holds for us a second
chance graciously offered and joyously
accepted you drink the blood of the Lost
land as it falls upon your darkened
Earth not strongly but to preserve and
once again deliver unto life
that
yeah I don't even know what you're
talking about I don't even know what any
of that means I don't know if any of
that is about
oh boy more white goop that's the same
stuff that crystals in a trescue was
made out
oh please tell me that the core of it
all is Crystal dimitrescue
please tell me
oh let it be so let it be true
well that looks like the real deal
ah
it's working
but is that really what you want
is this really what's going to make
everything better
maybe I don't know how would you know
hi
yeah
I've waited so long for you okay
Who Who Are You
my name is Miranda
your boss fight was disappointing
far too powerful for me to support
someone I had to lure you into this
realm so that you might willingly wash
your powers
no but case said did he
or did I
was an illusion
very convincing wouldn't you say
um
no way now you can become the vessel for
my
Mike Eva Evelyn evolution
Eva is in Evangelion
[Music]
well I can't run if you're alive
to manifest
he can save you Rose
[Music]
all right well
oh God what is happening oh hey oh hey
Dad
ah okay all right Dad oh
run
thanks pops let's go why can I never see
your face
because I've never actually seen your
face in all of the events of Resident
Evil 7 we're just a memory
in the mute of my seat or something like
that I don't know
thanks
why didn't you tell me who you really
were
why'd you let me call you Michael I
didn't want to complicate things I just
needed you safe hmm
yeah definitely going by a fake name
isn't complicating and I'm sorry I left
you alone
but I had to find a way out
and I did it's just ahead
um
well how about the power of a shotgun
away
come on
I'm going
you can't understand
Ethan persistent as always Rose now's
your chance go live a normal life make
friends no one will ever call you a
freak again
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
really lucky that that would be the
right way for it to work
don't worry dad
I've got this
you think Powers will allow you to stand
against me in the heart of my domain you
might foolish
oh
whoa I got Shadow Dodge no way
they'll never get me
wow I like that
or not you're the end you engines
[Music]
and these
and even if you were
what would be
and shame your father you are of two
different worlds uh-huh well yeah I know
this is all just in a fungus so like
they're oh whoops my shadow Dodge
absorb what do you mean absorb
I'm absorbing whoa I absorbed it
all right G Mega mice
and what can I do that
wow what is this well it's called me
being a badass
I've forgotten all of the buttons I
think it was controlled to absorb
something
I think whoa
holy crap
what's happening where are you where are
you oh time not today
oops that was not the right oh it's all
fine totally fine oh
oh you're like a freaking sand worm what
I dodged that I thought anyway
my reaction times are very good
no I don't think so
oh God I did not see that coming all
right okay all right okay okay hold on
hold on
[Music]
not have the power generator oh boy
that's not good it's why it must
you are the only one
whoa oh my God
that's a projectile
yeah
okay but what about one of these sure
oh
hahaha
how is that not hitting you
I know right pretty cool
wow
come on
got it okay I need to be close enough I
think to be able to use the superpower
and that looks close enough
that's what I'm talking about
what I am
oh you know I'm pretty cool and whatnot
what don't do
well that was the wrong thing
I dodged now
all right I dodged now oh sand worm time
uh-huh well you two also samezies
doubles names if this is a marginally
better boss fight I think I think they
kind of took it to heart when everyone
was saying like oh the boss fight's kind
of disappointing this is much better I
like the Dodge ability
oh God
oh come here you
where are you
oh never mind
sure
I'm so goddamn good where'd you go oh
God nope
God damn I'm good at shooting things
Point Blank oh Mister my God I missed
oh boy that was uh that was embarrassing
for me do you still not see there is no
happy ending all right
[Music]
oh boy oh oh God oh God why is it gonna
be goopy
your suffering will never end
whoa where'd that come from
whoa oh don't turn around pick up the
goddamn ammo
just won't give up
you really are
oh I have to shoot
Perfect all right never mind I got it
where are you where are you give me give
me you can I please oh come on
catching
okay you you you where are you where are
you where are you where are you oh God
nope
[Music]
so far so good I think
I don't know
what are you
oh boy
why
oh
why do birds fly
there will be whaling and Nash
well that seems strange to talk about
right now
what you've done it ten times this fight
I'm still just as shocked
oh why do I keep doing it the wrong time
no no no no no no
oh God
finally okay
foreign
supposed to be happening
uh-huh what about your struggle yeah
you're struggling all right
over here
who's my bulletproof plan
this
take her down
I like more Powers I like more Powers I
want more Powers I'm all about more
powers
[Music]
foreign
how about you're stupid
what about wanna leave
[Music]
in perfect vessel for my Eva uh I'm not
a goddamn Festival not some stupid
coffee I mean Rose
and you're done
guys
[Applause]
well
hey sweetie
oh my God
you're still going up
and even though I wasn't there with you
always watched over you
I'm so sorry I couldn't protect you
ever done
me
not this time
you lost your chance
and I don't regret it one bit
I left you
I mean never would have had this chance
talk face to face
to face
it's a very tender moment I won't make
any jokes about the fact that I don't
even know if Ethan has her face
so it's okay
I'm okay
I'm so proud of you
I'm so very proud of you
[Music]
the convenience of The Blocking of his
face
like they're so committed to this bit
and I know it's so tender and this is a
really important Story I mean it's very
sweet but God it's just I love you it's
so funny it reminds me like Dexter's
letter or no it was a Powerpuff Girls or
any kind of those characters where they
never showed the parents face
ah
anyway they're gonna be uh weirded out
when they find out I'm here back I'm
also back me too listen your dad might
be dead and gone but I'm here oh
dad
well in a world of fungal magic that
makes total sense
I do think they've actually improved the
mother Miranda fight I think that they
did that on purpose
oh yeah
do you think the little boy will be able
to touch the moon no but he can touch
the Moon is too far away wait what if he
has a rocket ship
okay then you can touch your butt it'd
be very very cold
you were being silly I don't think
die
hmm
so
this looks familiar because I feel like
this is kind of similar to how Resident
Evil 8 ended so did all of those events
take place just before
happy birthday the so-called ending cut
scene of re-8
sorry I missed last week
I have a lot of tests coming up you know
how it is
it is
it is
dirty calls
[Music]
I love you
yeah I found her
where else
the day of all days
we have a situation
you're needed
Evelyn
don't you ever call me that again oh
it's just a joke Rose
I couldn't show you things even Chris
doesn't know I can do
yeah tell me the punch line pal
we have a standout
we can handle it
yeah you're doing great job so far
I want you to keep it together Rose
so this is like this is the ending cut
scene from Mario
I know
interesting
I mean admittedly catching fungal energy
balls is a better uh defensive measure
than Ethan constantly going like
I'll take this knife on my wrists I'll
take your swords and bladed arms on my
Palms
yeah it's definitely
[Music]
but I just have one question where is
Lady D where's lady Dominic
hold on everyone
wait The Mercenaries The Mercenaries
additional orders
Chris wait a minute is it is it at is it
at the end is it at the end of these
hold on let me let me just let me just
see what's going on here
oh first person I forgot about that okay
let me try this I'm thinking that if I
beat these eventually towards the end
I'm going to see things that I'm going
to like all right so I know how to play
my score is 370 000. I need over 750
000.
nice God I'm good
shockingly everyone oh God never mind I
should never say anything ever
God I'm good God damn I'm good
whoa oh that's the end oh I didn't oh
oh do I get the oh I get the next one
let me go back to Chris or uh Ethan
because that was just too easy with that
one enemies will likely explode okay
that's probably gonna give me a lot more
trouble than I think but hey I'm fine I
don't even know what likely explode
means
foreign
exploding that is quite handy
huh
oh my God what is right here
you think that means they're Lady D
might might make an appearance
I love the likely explosion one million
130 000.
so that's an a which probably yeah gives
me the factory okay so I'm gonna end
this here because there might be lady
demetrescue over here there might be it
says additional orders there might be
I'm not 100 sure it may be so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will be back with one more episode and
you know what's going to be in that
episode I don't need to tell you what's
going to be in that episode because you
already know what's going to be in the
ad episode so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video
bye-bye